nous sommes dans les années 1660 sous le
règne de Louis XIV une nouvelle
construction est au centre de toutes les
attentions il s'agit du château de
versaill c'est un chantier hors norme
des sommes considérables qui ont été qui
ont été dépensé et Versailles c'est 1400
fontaines enfin c'est c'est c'est
délirant il faut bien dire que personne
ne peut rivaliser avec Versailles et ça
c'est très clair pour tout le monde pour
tout le monde sauf un le nouveau
propriétaire du château de Chantilly il
s'appelle le Grand Condé c'est le cousin
du roi et son plus grand rival il avait
dépensé une grande partie de sa fortune
en combattant le roi parce qu'il voulait
devenir calife à la place du calife et
ça n'a pas marché donc à la fin il a été
puni et enfermé dans son château et donc
que va-t-il faire et bien il va se
lancer dans une nouvelle bataille cette
bataille contre le Roi Soleil le prince
déchu ne va pas la mener sur
l'architecture du château mais sur un
autre aspect du domaine donc il s'est
concentré sur l'autre sujet à la mode à
cette époque c'était justement les
jardins le jardin la française est
inventé tous les nobles de France
veulent créer des jardins à la française
qui sont très à la mode comme tout
simplement symbole de leur puissance et
de leur richesse et le Grand Condé veut
montrer qu'il est presque voir aussi
puissant que le Roi à Versailles le
projet est extrêmement
ambitieux chantiller étant toujours
entouré d'une gigantesque zone
marécageuse à l'époque une seule
personne semble en mesure de relever
pareil défi son nom André Le naôre un
architecte et un paysagiste de génie
c'est déjà un jardinier bien installé
hein il a une quarantaine d'années sa
réputation est faite avec Fontainebleau
les Tuileries vol viiconte c'est
quelqu'un qui est un âge mû qui a des
connaissances à la fois architecturale
de mathématique enfin c'est le premier
grand paysagiste de l'histoire mais
problème quand le Grand Condé le contact
André Le nutre est déjà pris sur un
autre projet d'envergure Louis XIV le
choisit pour aménager jardins de
versaill je pense que pour le NRE
quitter versaill c'était une chose qui
était pas évidente il était attaché au
domaine de Royal et tous les autres
domaines étaient de domaines secondaires
chantilly n'est pas un domaine comme les
autres ici se trouve un élément rare et
longtemps considéré comme une faiblesse
une rivière qu'est-ce qu'on a chanti en
grande richesse on le voit en arrivant
c'est l'eau il y a beaucoup d'eau c'est
quand même fantastique à versa y en a
pas mais encore faut-il savoir la
maîtriser and lere donne son accord
accepte de mener de front les deux
chantiers il ne le sait pas encore mais
il va réussir à Chantilly des prouesses
techniques qui vont dépasser celles du
château de Versailles en
1662 les travaux sont lancés premier
objectif assaainir la zone marécageuse
pour arriver à à sécher ce genre de
terrain il faut drainer c'est-à-dire
qu'il faut essayer de faire arriver
toutes les eaux de part et d'autre sur
un canal central la zone à drainer est
considérable presque 7000 hectares
autant que Paris muros le nôtre imagine
alors un canal aux dimensions
gigantesques 60 m de large sur 2500 m de
long autant qu'une piste d'atterrissage
d'avion de ligne le but assécher les
marécages les travaux de terrassement et
de percement des canaux vont être
colossaux dans les dans les documents
d'archives on trouve régulièrement
mention d'équipe de 200 ouvriers qui
doivent creuser percer évacuer la terre
pour donner naissance à ces canaux
150000 m CB de terre sont décaissé de
quoi remplir plus de 5700 semiemorque le
grand canal oui ça a été un effort
énorme pour les équipes qui ont dû
travailler ici les ouvriers vont
rencontrer un autre problème en creusant
dans le sol la nappe fréatique qui est
peu profonde à Chantilly remonte ce qui
rend le drainage impossible André Le
nôre va devoir étanchéfier le fond de
son grand canal il avait une
connaissance hydraulique très très
pointue du site et il a pu créer des
canaux qu'il a recouvert d'argile afin
d'isoler effectivement le le fond de son
canal et d'éviter que les EOS de la
nappe remonte et remplissent ces canaux
à ce moment-là le le fond de son canal
étant bien isolé sur les berges de son
canal on pouvait drainer les EAU des
zones humides